David Boder: [In English] Chicago, June the 26th, 1950. This is Spool 9-21B, the second half of Spool 9-21. The first half is Dr. Lipschitz which we called 9-21A, the second is Mr. Nino Barzilai which we call 9-21B.
David Boder: [In Spanish] [Ininteligible] Ud. habla aquí en esta dirección...
David Boder: [In English] Paris, August 4th, Sunday, in the home for adult Jews. We are now going to interview a gentleman from Greece, Señor Nino Barzilai...who speaks Spanish.
David Boder: [In Spanish] Sr. Barzilai, dígame, ¿está Ud. nacido en Grecia?
Nino Barzilai: Sí señor, yo he nacido en Thessaloniki, en Grecia..
David Boder: Sí, ¿y cuántos años tiene Ud. ahora?
Nino Barzilai: 54 años.
David Boder: Tiene Ud. 54 años, ¡no parece Ud. tan...de tan edad!...dígame, entonces...¿y vivía Ud. es Grecia todo el tiempo?
Nino Barzilai: No señor, yo vivía en España, durante 20 años y al declararse la guerra civil de España, he vuelto a Grecia dónde tenía familia.
David Boder: ¿Es Ud. casado?
Nino Barzilai: Sí señor, tengo un hijo de 15 años.
David Boder: ¿Y su esposa?
Nino Barzilai: Y mi esposa también está aquí conmigo.
David Boder: Están aquí con Ud.; pues entonces señor, comience Ud. a decirnos...¿como pasó...la situación de ocupación de Grecia por los alemanes?
Nino Barzilai: Pues...mire Ud...hemos vuelto a Grecia como le he dicho, como teníamos familia, a que acabara la guerra civil de España y volver a nuestro sitio. Al llegar a Grecia, nos sorprendió la guerra ítalo-griega y, naturalmente, no hubo ocasión para volver a España sea porque las comunicaciones estaban interrumpidas, sea porque la guerra civil duraba todavía en España.
David Boder: ¿Y qué es su ocupación Sr. Barzilai?
Nino Barzilai: En Grecia, yo me ocupé de la venta de tejidos para trajes de señora. Estaba muy bien establecido, tenía mi despacho...
David Boder: En Grecia.
Nino Barzilai: En Grecia, en Atenas, cerca la [ininteligible].
David Boder: ¿Y qué hacía Ud. en España?
Nino Barzilai: En España yo me ocupaba de la bijouterie.
David Boder: Entonces se regresó Ud. a Grecia, ¿y ya estaban los alemanes ahí?
Nino Barzilai: Cuando regresé a Grecia los alemanes todavía no habían llegado.
David Boder: Y Bueno...
Nino Barzilai: Después cuando empezó la guerra italiana...Italia con Grecia, entonces, cuando pasó un poco de tiempo que volvieron los alemanes y entraron en Grecia; nosotros marchamos de Salónica para Atenas y nos establecimos en Atenas. Allá tenía un buen negocio como le he dicho, y cuando llegaron los alemanes, si hubo un anuncio en los periódicos, que todos los judíos debían de presentarse...como súbdito extranjero portugués, me he presentado también a...
David Boder: ¿Es Ud. portugués?
Nino Barzilai: Sí señor.
David Boder: ¿Nació Ud. en Portugal?
Nino Barzilai: No señor, soy de [ininteligible] mi familia era de [ininteligible]...entonces como...me presenté como portugués a las autoridades alemanas, con documentación portuguesa; como el gran rabino de Atenas era un pariente mío y por casualidad llevaba el mismo nombre que mi padre, los alemanes me lo tuvieron como hijo del gran rabino: me han puesto en un campo de concentración en Haïdari, Atenas, dónde pasé 5 meses y medio a trabajos forzados.
David Boder: ¿Qué clase de trabajo hacían allá en el campo de concentración?
Nino Barzilai: Nos daban a transportar piedras todo el día, y arena, de un sitio a otro, un trabajo bastante duro donde nos castigaban mucho y nos pegaban.
David Boder: ¿Y qué hacían con la arena?
Nino Barzilai: Era un trabajo que ellos habían hecho inventar para poder trabajar, para poder cansarnos, porque transportábamos las piedras de un sitio a otro y al otro día nos hacían volver las mismas piedras al mismo sitio. No había ni trabajos de fortificación ni trabajos de nada, solamente este transporte que nos hacían trabajar todos los días [ininteligible].
David Boder: Continúe Ud. señor, la recepción es buena
Nino Barzilai: Después de estar 5 meses y medio en el campo de concentración de Haïdari, llegó el día dónde recogieron a todos los judíos de Atenas y los trajeron a todos en el mismo campo de concentración. Allá estuvimos...unos ocho días juntos, todos los judíos, que han llegado de Atenas.
David Boder: Todavía en Grecia.
Nino Barzilai: En Grecia, sí. Y llegó el día de la deportación. Ese día de la deportación, a las cuatro de la mañana, nos han despertado y nos han dado diez minutos para estar prontos para marchar..
David Boder: ¿Cuánta gente cree que estuvo ahí?
Nino Barzilai: Allá creo que había cerca de dos mil.
David Boder: Dos mil, judíos. Miré Ud. Sr. Barzilai no tenemos la costumbre de hablar en esta investigación de mem...de papel, pero cómo Ud. tiene aquí el memorándum sobre los judíos en Grecia y no sabemos mucho de esto, vamos a hacer una excepción que lea Ud. el memorándum que Ud. tiene aquí.
Nino Barzilai: Y déjeme decirle en todo caso, que nosotros con el convoi que se formó para marchar en Polonia, sacaron a los súbditos extranjeros y nos han puesto en un convoi separado. Quiere decir los súbditos argentinos quedaron en el mismo campo de Haïdari, los súbditos españoles y portugueses nos han puesto en un tren separado, diciendo que íbamos a marchar para España y Portugal en un intervalo de 12 días. Después de viajar 8 días con el treno hasta llegar en Alemania, vinimos al campo de Bergen-Belsen y allá nos detuvieron hasta 14 meses.
David Boder: En Bergen-Belsen.
Nino Barzilai: En Bergen-Belsen, Alemania. Y de allá...cuando los ingleses, que estaban cerca de Berlín, vea Ud., nos han puesto en un treno y nos han dirigido a Börgermoor. Allá quedamos con el treno una noche.
David Boder: ¿Y dónde estaba su esposa y su hijo?
Nino Barzilai: Mi esposa y mi hijo, los encontré en el treno cuando íbamos para Alemania, para Bergen-Belsen.
David Boder: Sí.
Nino Barzilai: Los alemanes nos trajeron a la estación del treno y allá partimos juntos con el convoi de los españoles y portugueses.
Nino Barzilai: Y estuvimos juntos en Bergen-Belsen con mi señora y mi hijo.
David Boder: ¿En el mismo block, en el mismo...?
Nino Barzilai: En el mismo campo, en diferentes barracas.
David Boder: Sí.
Nino Barzilai: Las mujeres separadas, y los hombres separados.
Nino Barzilai: Allá estuvimos como le he dicho 14 meses. Cuando nos han puesto en el treno para marchar, que nos han dicho que íbamos a España, vinimos hasta Börgermoor. Allá hubo un par de bombardeos de la parte de los americanos, duró bastante fuerte toda la noche, por la mañana despertamos, vimos que los alemanes habían abandonado el treno; y quedamos solos allá en un campo...abandonados completamente. Marchamos unos cuantos para salir cerca...de unas casas alemanas para ver lo que se pasaba. Entonces fuimos a buscar un poco de comida porque nosotros no cocinábamos nada, lo poco que nos dieron para el viaje se había acabado. Y encontramos unas cuantas patatas que nos han dado desde allá, hemos vuelto al treno e hicimos bouillir esas patatas para poder comer alguna cosa. Mientras tanto, voces corrieron que los americanos habían llegado. Y poco tiempo después, fue con tanto júbilo y tanta alegría que recibimos a los americanos que vinieron a [ininteligible]. Su primera preocupación fue darnos algo caliente de comer, nos han traído una sopa que nos han servido en el treno mismo y, después de un día, nos han dicho que nos iban a trasladar. Nos avisaron que nos debíamos de reunir todos en la plaza del pueblo para poder marchar todos juntos en unas casas que nos habían preparado para estar, hasta que marcháramos todos...[Ininteligible]
David Boder: ¿Qué hacían los 14 meses en Bergen-Belsen?
Nino Barzilai: Nosotros como súbditos extranjeros no trabajábamos, estábamos encerrados en las barracas, encerrados allá.
David Boder: ¿Y no vinieron...los españoles o alguien de...cerca de España...o de [ininteligible]?
Nino Barzilai: Nadie, nadie hizo nada por nosotros. Se escribieron muchas cartas y ninguna contestación ha llegado.
David Boder: ¿Fueron Uds. solamente judíos?
Nino Barzilai: Todos judíos.
David Boder: Todos judíos.
Nino Barzilai: En el mismo campo de Bergen-Belsen juntábamos nosotros, súbditos argentinos y súbditos turcos. Los súbditos turcos antes de marchar nosotros, habían marchado ya, ocho días antes que nosotros fueron liberados. Eso lo aprendimos después, al salir nosotros.
David Boder: ¿Liberados por quién?
Nino Barzilai: Se dice que los acompañaron hasta la frontera suiza y que allá el consulado se encargó de ellos.
David Boder: Bueno, entonces diga Ud. ahora, vamos a ver que...dígame...
Nino Barzilai: Como le he dicho, que después que fuimos liberados por los americanos, los americanos nos han enviado a Francia...hemos, la primera estación de Francia que hemos hecho fue...[Interrupción, no audio]
David Boder: No, no...it will be good, wherever...¿Y después? [Ininteligible] No, está bien.
Nino Barzilai: No recuerdo bien. Nos han dirigido verso París y todos los déportées que hemos llegado a París somos altamente reconocientes al gobierno francés y al pueblo francés en general por el apoyo favorable que nos dan ellos. Nos han dado todas las facilidades, nos han vestido a todos, que estábamos todos descalzados y desnudos, y nos han dado la buena comida que no olvidaremos nunca lo que la Francia ha hecho por todos los deportados.
David Boder: Aja. ¿Y ahora qué está Ud. haciendo señor?
Nino Barzilai: Nosotros estamos todavía en el centre de accueil de la calle [ininteligible], todavía no hemos encontrado ninguna casa para podernos establecer. Mi hijo lo he puesto en una escuela francesa dónde está aprendiendo un oficio.
David Boder: ¿Qué oficio está aprendiendo?
Nino Barzilai: Ebanistería.
David Boder: Aja. Ebanistería.
Nino Barzilai: Yo como tengo también el oficio de electricista, me han conseguido la casa del trabajo.
David Boder: Le han conseguido.
Nino Barzilai: Sí, si...y poco a poco estoy empezando a trabajar. Y creemos que podemos quedar aquí en Francia, por la zona.
David Boder: Y establecerse.
Nino Barzilai: Y establecernos. Aquí llevo una lista que será muy interesante para todos los judíos de Grecia que se encuentran en el extranjero. Una lista de los pocos judíos que volvieron a Grecia, de cada provincia en provincia de Grecia, con sus habitantes antes de la guerra, y los que quedaron y volvieron.
David Boder: Bueno.
Nino Barzilai: En la provincia de Didimoticho eran 900 judíos, hoy han vuelto 33, se han perdido 96 por ciento; en la aldea Orestiada [Interrupción, no audio]...han vuelto 3, 98 por ciento; Alexandroupolis, 140 judíos, 97 por ciento; Komotini, 819, han vuelto 28, 96%; Xanthi, 550, han vuelto 6, 99%, Macedonia, en Kavala, 2.100 judíos, han vuelto 42, 98% de perdida; en Drama, 1.200, han vuelto 79, 97%; [ininteligible] 600, no han vuelto más que 3, 98%; Tessaloniki, la gran comunidad judía, 56.000, han vuelto 1.950, 96%.
David Boder: 96% ¿perdidos?
Nino Barzilai: Perdidos, sí señor. Veroia, 460 judíos, han vuelto 131...
David Boder: Bueno señor...
Nino Barzilai: 32%.
David Boder: ¿Ud. puede darme una copia de ese papel o a dónde se lo pedimos?
Nino Barzilai: Con mucho placer, sí señor.
David Boder: Bueno.
Nino Barzilai: Yo le daré la copia. Continuaremos...[Ininteligible].
David Boder: [Ininteligible]
Nino Barzilai: Kastoria, 900 judíos, 35 han vuelto, 96% de pérdida; Florina, 400 judíos, 74 han vuelto, 84%; Thessalia, 520, 360, 31%...
David Boder: Bueno señor, [ininteligible] si Ud. me da la copia. Entonces señor...le agradezco mucho por su información y especialmente [ininteligible] porque yo intento de irme a México y un reporte...[extremos precipitadamente]